[Music]
[Music]
so this series and the speaker's Buffalo
Syria to represent that trajectory in
her critical
I'm going to pack schedule and there is
a reception after
and join us
I just like to thank Fox Caro for
introducing your employer who was our
speaker tonight Fox say a few things
about your export and I'd also like to
thank captain Ignacio
it was a professor at Emerson College
and one of the people who did the first
sir is this the second of a serious tone
there was a stereo stuff four or five
years ago on Civic Arts much smaller
than this series and this series is part
of the ongoing colloquium for
comparative Media Studies
which is also really please doesn't
opportunity to introduce Terra clear to
you so area is a preeminent and
award-winning media artist and
interactive story creator if
the honor of knowing them for a number
of years and elect to describe this work
you know the way that he does
so if you look up you look him up online
you'll find that he described stories
that you play like instruments and
instruments for telling stories I think
this is quite true that you'll see so
just to give you a sense of who he is
it's
that'll work he's had a few different
roles over the years so we're probably
at least a number of people here have
heard of scaler
I mean this is the system that's used in
academic menus over 10,000 registered
users an open-source tool for publishing
scholarly works
eret is that creative director of the
group responsible or a scalar so that's
a one
the major academic engagement with this
work also the Vectra German this was a
pioneering experiments will online a
journal bring people together for
workshops academics and video designers
that are to create interactive or
versions of their work it is intense
kind of workshops with during the
summers and so I think the earth was
also creative director of this journal
as well but the very groundbreaking work
for you Mobile's scholarship but beyond
this he also doesn't work his own
expensive so the boundary director of
opportune creating and publishing for
retailing apps these are targeted
naturally internationally like indeed
are earning over 500,000 downloads so
you think about interactive stories that
a hit popular culture outside of typical
times people say interactive story
popular culture they think something
like that video tease these are
interactive stories some applications
that have covered such a huge number of
users and their experimental formats
he's a developer of an ugly operating
school that combines visual language of
comics and unity II mentioned and just
these are a few examples that just
suggests that his work has
from building platforms for others to
use new forms of Chester driven
interactive story we work on a national
endemic amenities project around cuff
gestures and prosper ease forward
interactive comics large-scale academics
these really spans the gamut of kind of
digital media production now when I
first personally encountered his work
about was about ten years ago I was
completely blown away
and so there was a system that will
speak to you some about today called a
Reuben and lullaby and so I won't say
too much about it but just this idea
that the work was so poignant and the
emotion Laden it waved up with intrinsic
to your connections within the work and
play like instruments like I said before
a striking and another standout project
of his is a blue velvet that and this is
a corporation with academic scholars for
effective internal wear his design
sensibility is captured for me not only
the kind of pain of the earth
Daphne it Orleans but also there's a
kind of impressive magical moment at
some point during this work because in
the Institute described through the
interactive metaphor but murky human
driven causes of the disaster
discrimination that Kannamma qualities
and so forth and so for me this place to
where interaction design can begin to
suggest something about social
engagement impact and justice through a
visual metaphor that's a completely
struck we should go about that is work
the creator of it and for me that I
think that the creator of this kind of
poignant and nuanced work also just last
year I picked up in New York Times and
they read an article let's reimagine the
way that we engage with music digitally
we used to use minor notes we used to
Charles Mingus have this psychotherapist
by designer though it's he had all this
kind of insight to about him when you
read them well as it's also done a
network that was we've got the New York
Times about being decorating this note
so that any listen to music all the
context and information in history can
visually this kind of work so completely
to protect prospective work and then
finally we just like to say that means
someone whose work I deeply admire
myself I learned from
it aspired by some way having a kind of
ongoing creative practice there's
someone that I would like to repeat just
want to finally say thank you so much
Fox for that introduction
I've actually told people that I've
wanted to be you on occasion as well so
the feeling's mutual
all right let me shift over to my
presentation
oops that's the last slide we know the
first slide okay so again thank you all
for coming thank you James and Fox and
Rissa for making this possible and for
the invitation it's really an honor and
a pleasure to be here with you so
obviously as you hear I've had kind of
long playing interest in digital
storytelling and that really leads me to
my topic tonight which is making stories
unstuck which kind of begs the question
well our story's stuck I mean aren't we
kind of drowning in stories stories are
everywhere yes that's true it doesn't
feel like stories are stuck but I think
if we look closely the story the
narrative the thing that's crafted by a
human for other humans with internal
structure and a kind of integrity of
design it's still tough for our
narratives in the digital space to make
a leap from one platform to another
without some kind of manual translation
happening and so for me I define kind of
stuckness for the purposes of this talk
as a story that can't get out of the
platform that it was conceived in
without some help without some manual
labor sometimes a great deal of manual
labor so why should we care to unstick
stories I think one of the reasons is
actually just quality of life if we find
a story meaningful we should be able to
bring it with us in all our digital
contexts without necessarily having to
purchase separate products or translate
manual
we through a laborious process we should
be able to build on remix without having
to transcribe ourselves and maybe it's
because we're kind of too in love with
our own technology but I think more
likely because the forces of platform
ownership and exclusivity are very
strong as designers and producers we
seem to be reluctant to admit and act on
the fact that our digital narratives
have value apart from the interfaces in
which they originally debuted so I'll
give an example for my own work this is
a project called public secrets that was
done for the vectors journal I was one
of the I always like to clarify I'm one
of two creative directors for the
vectors Journal Regan Kelly is the other
creative director who did some excellent
work and our work is in very different
modes this project is a series of
testimonies from women that Sharon
recorded who are women who are
incarcerated in California she posed as
a legal advocate you're not supposed to
be able to go in and make these
recordings but she went ahead and did it
and the piece is comprised of several
hundred audio files that are the
testimonies of these women there are
also interwoven with theoretical
reflections
Sharon's own words and other elements so
I'll let a little bit of video run in
the background ok great
so the piece is the the testimonies are
contextualized in a kind of grid
structure as you move through the piece
headlines kind of excerpting pieces from
each testimony up here in this grid and
they move and change and appear in
different context from biographical to
theoretical to stories about life inside
and life outside the prison so I'm very
proud of the design I'm proud of the
impact that it's helped the testimonies
to have but I have to admit if the
design disappeared and the testimony has
remained the piece would still have
tremendous value right the the value was
really in the words of the women if the
testimony disappeared in the design
remained there would be some value but
the value would be greatly diminished
but currently these testimonies are
stuck in
interface they can't get out and you
might say well this is a piece that's
done in flash so just don't do things in
flash right flash is a proprietary
technology it's bound to die at some
point so don't do that
but actually would argue that it's not
really an issue of flash because we
could have produced this piece and
completely open standards with
technology that's not proprietary and it
still would be quite difficult for a lay
person experiencing this piece to take
these stories out and bring them into
the rest of their lives it's not a
trivial task you probably have to be a
developer in order to do it
so even though we have excellent
resources like the piece acid-free bits
by Nick Montfort no award tripped ruin
this excellent set of recommendations
for digital creators about how to create
work that will last that will ensure
that at least in some form or fashion it
can be resurrected or poured into a new
format or made accessible in some way or
another this should be required reading
I think for everybody creating a digital
it's not necessarily an issue of
preservation I'm talking about because
even if you followed all these
recommendations if the original platform
were to fall out or that or to disappear
in some way you would still probably
need to be a developer to access the
data and the content of those stories
and to make use of them but what about
the average user who is just interested
in circulating a digital narrative not
just in the future after some
technological apocalypse but today right
now not just within the platforms in
which these stories were created but
across and between those platforms I
think in some ways we can look at it as
a question of our problem of human
centered design looking at how to Center
our narrative efforts on the people
experiencing the stories instead of the
techniques that we're using to deliver
them which all too often becomes the
focus myself included a human centered
approach to storytelling recognized that
we experience stories in a linear way in
fact we can experience them in no other
way and would respect that linearity yes
in the code these stories are attached
to objects and agents and their
spatialized in 3d worlds but we still
experience them one piece at a time
sequence and even in the biggest
triple-a games it can still be
surprisingly difficult to find a linear
narrative account of exactly what's
happened to us in this world many large
studio the scale story games will have a
kind of journal that'll keep track of
what you do but how many of us actually
will boot up the console load the
program find our saved game and just
read that journal even though we might
have a desire to experience that story
again and our playthrough that's not
really a really optimal way of of
reading that content why can't I get it
as an e-book why can't I get it in some
other format that I'm more likely to
engage with and so this an example of
ways in which I think we don't really
prioritize as creators how these stories
could live and how the users experience
and engage them at those stories could
live beyond the original the original
encounter so as a case study and kind of
what this might be like if we were to
enable stories in these ways I'm gonna
turn to our old friend Hamilton as a
example of the power of unsticking
digital narrative unstuck stories so if
we look at Hamilton it's a text that in
some ways in many ways it's been
optimized for digital distribution this
is from an article in Fast Company the
cast album is actually key to this so it
says ticket scarcity is motivated
creator lin-manuel Miranda to create an
entire world around Hamilton so that
people and especially young people can
feel like a part of the movement even if
they can't get into the theater the
strategy began with the cast album and
if you're familiar with it you know that
the entire story of the musical is
contained in the songs so you can get
the songs and you have the whole thing
other elements here Miranda's dense
lyrical accomplishments something to
geek out over and memorize so the
density of it kind of demands an
engagement a memorization that almost
kind of proves your loyalty to the text
Miranda himself wrote 23 annotations to
the show's lyrics on the website genius
so genius this lyric annotation website
taking the story of the show
and encoding it in a digital way so that
it can be annotated and those
annotations can be playback in sync with
the music either in the genius website
or back in Spotify so this the fact that
the story has been mobilized in
way that because all of the story is
contained in the songs you put those
songs on a streaming service like
Spotify if you get instant distribution
all over the place and sites like genius
which allow the lyrics to move and take
new forms so I actually used the lyrics
from genius to make another
instantiation as well took several songs
broke them down into syllables and
created lyric videos a couple of lyric
videos based on two of the songs and
then partnered with a YouTube channel to
kind of distribute them a little bit to
see what would happen if mobilizing the
stories in this way would get a get a
response so I'm going to show an example
of an especially dense passage from the
song non-stop I'm just a little clip
from it so you can see how this plays
out and how you're able to actually see
all the characters in this kind of dense
text and what they're doing in a way
that might not be as apparent just
listening to it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so some of the responses to this
after it was posted some YouTube
contents comments please for the love of
God give me all chorus pieces in this
format there are things like the little
hey and the voice of BER after 550 that
I had never noticed until now
thanks I like how it shows the lyrics by
the syllables can some way to tell me
how to make these I need to know for
science okay so ended up getting the two
songs that we did ended up getting over
400,000 views on Facebook and YouTube
and obviously yes Hamilton mania is
going on Hamilton is kind of the unicorn
of unicorns but mesmerizing was a word
that was used often and many comments
that people feel like they're able to
engage more with the story because it's
been mobilized in this particular way
for such a dense text so I think there's
some evidence here that stories kind of
want to be unstuck and that there's a
response there's something that the
public would would do with stories if
they were unstuck and more available
more frictionless in the way that
they're able to move through the world
right now a tremendous amount of labor
is expended moving stories from one
format to another and you know one of
the most common ways is video right so
once YouTube be kind of became a thing
we have this such an excellent video
distribution mechanism that all of a
sudden all of culture is being converted
into video and so that it can be
distributed and so that it can move and
it's frictionless way from one place to
another I can't tell you how many times
I've been frustrated because I'm trying
to find a tutorial and it's only
available as a video it would be so much
shorter to just actually type it out and
print it out so that I could follow the
instructions but I have to watch a
20-minute video to figure out how to do
this thing but it's that's happening
because it is such a frictionless
delivery system right now and so all
this effort is being expended converting
narrative from other forms into video
through fan videos through lyric videos
through all different kinds of things
and so we could just let these processes
unfold as they as they are but I think
there's something deeper going on here
and I think if we try to enable it
deliberately some interesting things
might happen
so if we were to decide to deliberately
unstick digital stories I'm not just
talking about an individual story here
and there I'm talking about digital
stories as a whole is this something
that's even possible are there too many
formats too many idiosyncrasies in terms
of how different narratives work for us
to even think about attempting this and
maybe more importantly this has got to
be have been done already right I mean
there's so many different formats out
there for narrative interactive fiction
formats but those tend to be around a
kind of parser based simulation of a
literary world
well there's text encoding there's TEI
but that tends to be more about kind of
encoding text for publication or for
scholarly study
there's hypertext but hypertext doesn't
really have a concept of temporality
there's RSS which does have temporality
but the scale is all wrong closed
captioning which is actually not bad
it's actually kind of close to to maybe
what we're looking for in terms of the
resolution it's very small chunks but
there's no real semantic data associated
with it and it's also bound up in these
video standards so what could this thing
be that enables digital narratives to
become more mobile so my journey to try
and answer that question started really
completely by accident and in a very
unexpected place
I'm started with the Nintendo Wii oddly
enough so when Nintendo announced the
Wii in its motion controller I was very
excited about that and I went and got my
kids DUPLO and I built myself a little
Wii Remote that was supposedly about the
same size and shape as what had been
announced and started waving it around
like crazy my office to try and figure
out what kind of interactions would be
enabled by this and once it was actually
released you know hack started to appear
so you could play with the Wii Remote
with your PC or your Mac and see what
kind of projects you could create with
it I was very interested in music
interactions musical interactions and
quickly realized that in order to do a
lot of musical interaction the gestures
couldn't be like waving things around
and was going to get too tiring so I was
trying to find a gesture that was
repeatable that was rhythmic that
wouldn't be tiring if you did it many
times and I kind of came across the
horizontal tilt so taking the road and
just really tilting it
back and forth and you know this is
something that could be repeated many
times it wasn't too tiring it did have a
kind of percussive Allis aspect or
musical aspect to it so I wanted to play
with that gesture and had the idea to
well what if what if you put some music
on and just by tilting you'd be kind of
waggling your way through song lyrics
and so every time you cross the access
you would advance one syllable into the
lyrics of the song and you can almost
see a kind of invisible bar that the
letters of the song would be hanging off
of and that would kind of track
one-to-one with how your remote was
moving one-to-one was kind of the holy
grail of we interaction and it didn't
happen very often so an opportunity to
do that was was kind of exciting so this
all sounded good it was pretty easy to
put together but then to create a demo
of it I had to decide on what song that
was going to use and so I turned to a
personal favorite which is another kind
of dense lyrical accomplishment that I
got over and memorized from Kurt Elling
second studio album it's a piece called
Tanya Jean and it's actually a cover
it's a cover of Donald Byrd's
tanja which is on Dexter Gordon's album
one flight up and this is this an epic
song it's about 18 minutes long with
this amazing solo by Dexter Gordon and
there's there's a tradition of jazz
vocalists kind of taking earlier
standards that don't have lyrics and
adding their own lyrics there's great
examples of this there's horrible
examples of this but Kurt Elling does
one better and that he doesn't just
provide lyrics to the melody of the song
he does lyrics to the whole saxophone
solo Dexter Goren's entire solo so it
becomes this kind of stream of
consciousness very dense lyrical piece
kind of a spiritual encounter being
described it's very evocative and again
ripe for memorization so that okay this
would be a good you know test to really
kind of demonstrate the tetanus
technology in this project so here's a
section of the original piece
[Music]
alright and here's that same section of
Kurt Elling version of that piece with
this Wii Remote performance of the
lyrics happening at the same time
[Music]
okay so that that was you can't tell by
the enthusiasm it was really fun to
perform but one thing that was fun about
it was not just tracking the song there
was something unexpected about it and it
was something in this trigger this
switching the axis from one side to
another and the fact that it was just
kind of this nonspecific command you
know we're so used to in our interface
having these very indexical and symbolic
actions now I'm pushing a button I'm
clicking something I'm doing a gesture
that's very you know defined and this
felt very kind of loose non specific and
all it was was a next command and the
system is delivering the next syllable
you know again repeatedly in quick
succession but there was something about
that that felt unlike other interactions
that I'd had with with digital stories
and just powerful and just felt really
good so I kind of made note of that and
started to build on it and so that led
to this piece ribbon and lullaby that
Fox was talking about so ribbon lullaby
is a love story an interracial love
story between two people who are having
their first fight on a park bench and it
was my first project for the iPhone and
you interact with the piece by tilting
it back and forth to cut from one
character to the other and you can
affect their emotions through gestures
so if you stroke someone's face the
screen will turn blue and you'll kind of
calm them down or if you shake the phone
whoever you're looking at will get angry
and the idea is to have both characters
kind of express themselves enough that
they get their point across but not so
much that they drive the person away and
so there's there's multiple endings but
really you can just actually enjoy it as
an audio-visual kind of experience even
if you're not getting into the game of
how do I get to one ending or not or
another so I'm gonna start this going
here
so the score is totally dynamic and
again having applied this tilting
interaction first two words here two
images I found that it was still very
satisfying and there was again something
about how it's a nonspecific interaction
and it isn't even that as you tilt you
one way you see one character and you
see the other sometimes you tilt and you
just get a closer view or a different or
a more distant view of the same
character but there's something about
this kind of nonspecific next command
that was very satisfying again both the
words and now with images okay
so that piece was a collaboration with
the artist Ezra Clayton Daniel's a comic
artist who at that time was based in
Chicago now he's based in LA and that
collaboration developed into a larger
one on a project called up great soul so
this is his science fiction story I'll
kind of Cronenberg s story I'm about a
couple who undergoes this experimental
therapy to rejuvenate their bodies and
it ends up creating these kind of odd
clones of themselves and I'll give a
quick plug here actually the print
version of upgrade soul was just
released in the last week so definitely
go out and pick that up and it actually
has just already been optioned for a
movie deal so congratulations to Ezzor
on that give him a shout out so with
upgrades soul we were really exploring
the did the visual language of comics
and what that could be on screens I'm
gonna go ahead and start this preview
running in the background so here we're
no longer operating with tilt gestures
we're operating with swipes and it was
designed for the iPad although it works
on the iPhone as well one of the things
that we were interested in an upgrade
soul is is one making sure that you
could always go forward and back you
could always swipe forward always swipe
back too many digital comics we've seen
take control away from the user to play
a non interactive video sequence and so
you're kind of promised this
interactivity and then it's yanked away
from you and it happens over and over
and over again so we wanted to make sure
you can always go forward and back but
the other thing is that all the sound in
upgrade soul is musical sound some of it
can be can kind of function as sound
effects but also functions as music so
literally every time you swipe your
musical sound it might be a note or
phrase so we can encode melodies as
you're going through and swiping through
the piece and again finding that even
though it wasn't a tilt there's still
this kind of nonspecific swipe give me
the next thing was still really powerful
and compelling because you didn't know
what was necessarily going to happen
you were probably going to get a new
panel but it could just be a sound or it
could be a new piece of dialogue showing
up or it could be an animation and
working on it in the context of a piece
which had such connections to print
actually helped me to realize that what
this thing is that I was so obsessed
with was a page-turner it was nothing
more complicated than a page turn but
made digital and obviously this wasn't
anything new I mean press return to
continue press spacebar to continue I'm
using software right now that I'm
pressing the arrow button to continue
this is not new but mobilizing it at a
musical scale at a performative scale
where it wasn't just stepping through
chunks of text because it had to be
parsed out that way brought something
different to the table and I began to
look at other works that I had done in
the past and realize that this mechanic
was kind of running through as a common
three and theme through a lot of the
things that I had done so in this
example strange rain this is an app that
I did before upgrade Sol it's a rain
stimulator that basically has a story
inside it where you're tapping the
screen to get the thoughts of a
character who's kind of going through an
existential crisis so you're tapping to
get individual thoughts or you're
dragging to get sequences of thoughts
and realize that this is the same
mechanic it is a situation where the
user controls when and the author
controls what and there's a tension
that's implicit in there especially when
you deliver it at a kind of musical
scale where you're talking about phrases
and notes every time you tap the screen
and step in upgrade so you get a little
phrase like a little - no - chord phrase
that loops and the piece develops as it
loops so this idea of you know discrete
linear sequences with musical elements
in it was operating at a low level on
all these different pieces and I started
to kind of put the pieces together I
started to think about especially
with strange rain I got a lot of
requests from people who wanted more
stories you know there's one story
that's kind of baked into the piece but
they wanted more stories they wanted to
add their own stories and I started
thinking about how this would be
accomplished but I didn't want to build
a whole system just for that one app
like I would like those stories to be
able to live and move maybe from one app
to another just so I didn't have to
rebuild this facility over and over
again so started thinking about what if
there is a format that organized
narrative content into stats which in
some level is so simple it seems like
the most idiotic thing ever like we're
just gonna make a format around things
being in lists and happening in a linear
order do we really need to create this
but again like I had said looking
through these other formats I couldn't
really find anything that did exactly
what I was looking for and so I ended up
coming up with this format just very ad
hoc called stepwise it's an xml-based
format I put it up on github and started
to realize that one of the things that
was compelling for me about it in which
I thought could have some potential is
not just that as organizing narratives
into discrete stats and sequences but
that part of what was important was
saying who was doing what at what time
so who does what when the idea that say
in a complex you know text like the
Hamilton example we're not just saying
what words are being spoken we're saying
who spoke and who's speaking them we're
identifying that semantically so that
anyone processing something in this
format would know who was saying what
when and that's information that's not
transmitted in a video and a fan B or a
lyric video you don't get that
information about who is saying what at
what time and that that actually became
even more powerful if you expand that
who to include instruments in the score
so if there's a piano playing while this
character is saying X well that piano is
also a character and it is saying
something at a particular time or even
more abstract concepts what's happening
in the lighting or maybe there's
theoretical ideas and this goes back to
some of the vectors work where we're
trying to enact academic theory in a
database and kind of bring it to life so
people are speaking instruments are
singing ideas are having in flew
all of these are fair game to be
chronicled in a format like this so I'm
thinking about how you would build
stories in this format I realized or I
started thinking well you probably want
something kind of like a garage band but
it's really for multimodal content right
so instead of tracks we would have
characters and we could put in those
tracks texts images video audio all
different kinds of things but I don't
have the resources to build GarageBand
so I came up with the next best thing as
many others before me have which is the
spreadsheet so Google sheets to save the
day
so the spreadsheet format in Google
sheets was actually perfect because we
can organize columns for each character
and rose to represent steps in time it's
cloud cloud enabled and there's an API
that you can use to get data out of it
and so it became a really critical way
to kind of play with this idea of how to
how to build stories in this way and
that led to the creation of a site
called step works it's at step dot works
as the URL and this is really a place to
kind of play with this idea what if
digital stories were more mobile could
be more easily moved from one platform
into another or from one stage or
location to another so I'm going to show
you a little bit about how the site
works here I'm gonna find my cursor okay
it's gonna
okay so just to give a quick demo so the
way the site works is it has a series of
stages which are basically templates
ways of presenting stories so you can
pick a template there's a few that are
already here I'm gonna pick this one
called text messages so basically it
displays any multi character dialog as a
text message chain so here's that you
might recognize it from the spreadsheet
that was just showing this is the
classic Abbott and Costello who's on
first so as I tap the keyboard or click
I'm stepping through this dialogue okay
so let's say I want to make my own that
fits into this same format I can just
hit new and if I've got a Google account
it'll prompt me to create a new copy of
this starter document that comes
preloaded with a few different
characters for different characters I
only need two so I'm gonna delete two of
these columns here and we're gonna call
character one amber and character to
Alisha I like using my cousin's names so
this first one is we're just going to
say hello and Alisha and we'll delete
that and say hi amber how are you I'm
fine okay you see why I don't have a
career in film my writing is nothing
greatest so then let's go ahead and
publish this document
and let's follow the link in the
document back to the site okay so now
we've got our scintillating dialogue
going here okay now let's say I want to
add a little bit of a musical score to
this all I need to do is add another
character we're gonna call this
character piano and let's just do a
major chord here see e and g and then
the next step we'll do just a low C and
I'm just gonna copy these so it'll
repeat okay let's go back and hit
refresh okay so we've got our musical
score but you've noticed something
interesting is going on which the piano
is a real character so the notes that
it's playing it's actually staying in
the text/chat so this probably isn't
what we actually want so I can add a
little extra item here to the end of
here that's hidden okay so that means
this one actually speak it out loud or
show it as dialog but it will still play
the notes here we go got our amazing
musical score okay
so again just a quick demo of how step
works works but the one of the
interesting things about it is I can now
go to stages and I can pick another
stage here so let's pick vocal grid this
is the one that was used for the
Hamilton example and if I hit load I
pick my demo and now that same story is
rendered in a different format but still
with the music playing okay there's
obviously other stages that you can load
the same story into and see it play out
in that way all right so let me jump
back to the keynote okay every piece
that you create in stepworks gets a
custom URL so you could take that and
share it online because
includes the URL to the Google sheets
document and you know build and play and
share in that way you can also get
access to the underlying XML that is
being generated behind the scenes so
through all this work and kind of
playing with this and experimenting and
seeing what the possibilities might be
an ethos kind of started to emerge that
I began to feel strongly about and I
realized that in my own work I'd seen
too many cases where stories got stuck
and couldn't be further transmitted but
usually because the technology died but
also I saw other other aspects of
storytelling that we're being revealed
by this that I also wanted to encourage
and kind of participate in so I kind of
call this the good guest good host ethos
the first part of it is be a good guest
and let your stories go on the road so
let your stories become guests in other
contexts okay that changes the way that
you write so if you are writing a story
that depends on all of these audio
visual effects that are only available
in the original context that you did
view that story that story is not a very
good guest it's going to go other places
but it's gonna make all these demands of
that place that it goes just like a poor
guest in real life and it's not going to
be well-received and it may not work at
all they rip the content the kind of
essence of what you're trying to get
across may not be communicated and this
by the same token be a good host to give
other people's stories a place to stay
in your work okay so when you're
creating a form at a stage that your
story is going to live and we'll think
about other stories that might want to
live there too and what might their
needs be stories that might have a
different timescale or different types
of content different numbers of
characters different elements like that
different formal characteristics or
content characteristics and so be a good
guest be a good host let your stories go
on the road and give other people's
stories a place to stay so how might
this work in practice
so all of this is you know still very
very early in rough so I'm going to give
you some rough examples one of which is
this NASA insight project so I had the
good fortune of being selected to be
part of a NASA
social team this is a group of 40 people
that they pick to promote a given launch
or some event that's happening at NASA
so in this case it was the launch of the
insight mission to Mars the most recent
mission to Mars that should be landing
in November so you know we got to have a
tour of Annenberg Vandenberg Air Force
Base we got to go to the launch pad and
see the launch all of which was amazing
and wonderful and we were also supposed
to be posting you know to social media
about what was going on so I thought
okay this is gonna be a good example to
try stepworks kind of in the wild and
see how it performs so in trying to
figure out what I would do I realized
that on the NASA site for the mission
there's a timeline that shows all the
missions to Mars no matter which country
did it and the outcome so you know in
the beginning the outcomes are all
pretty bad like this thing blew up this
thing fail this went off course then you
have the Viking mission which is the
first successful landing and then after
that you still get a lot of things
blowing up and going of course but
eventually you get into where we're at
now where there's a lot of successful
missions and so that in itself has kind
of an arc to it
so it kind of took that information and
all the outcomes and put it together in
a piece using stepworks
and basically decided to sauna fly the
data by turning each mission into a
musical note so each mission is
represented by a note and I quantized
the missions by year so if there are
four missions in a year you get a four
note chord and then I kind of set the
set these chords and notes in a kind of
cosmos II you know since the sci-fi kind
of setting and created this piece that
was an Instagram Keys where you'll see
all of the outcomes of all the missions
happening in sync with the music as it
plays
okay so the whole history of Mars
exploration in a few few notes and
chords and then I turned it into sheet
music so one of the things that that
that I think you know was successful
about this experiment is that it showed
how if NASA is being a good guest and
allowing the story of these missions to
go out and let's say it was a
standardized format I actually had to
manually translate it but let's say it
was a standardized format it would have
been easy for me to pick that up to add
music to it to add the visuals to it
from all the missions and then if there
was another stage that turned that into
notation that could also be done
automatically that wouldn't be difficult
and so you've got a story that was never
designed to be a performative story
becoming that and kind of taking
transforming from one shape to another
I'm in these different media in these
different formats so another example the
good being a good host is a piece that I
developed it's a documentary piece and
it's the kind of the first long-form
piece that I tried to do with step works
it's called rewriting relearning
creative collaborations in the digital
humanities so it's a documentary about
the vectors project a lot of these
collaborations between designers and
scholars were pretty impactful for
everybody involved and so I went back to
some of the folks that have worked on
vectors and just talked to them about
their experience and collected ephemera
from the design process to kind of use
to illustrate what it was like so I'll
open up and show a little bit of that
now
[Music]
okay so Karen Kaplan here is talking
about kind of the impetus for her to
decide to join the vectors project it
can apply so a little bit about how this
is structured you'll notice that the
piece is one it's unfolding I'm actually
pressing keys on the keyboard to advance
it step by step and you can replay by
clicking any of these items can we play
the audio obviously we're bringing in
video and imagery that are ephemera from
the from the design process for some of
these projects the reason why it's
broken up into these chunks is actually
I've split it on edits so every place
where I edited the original audio to get
rid of an on or an hour for clarity that
actually embedded as a scene so
sometimes you'll get kind of strange you
know little fragments of things but I
like the fact that that labor of the
editing which is usually completely
effaced when you're watching a
documentary is still in here so if these
were actually you know index by time you
could actually reconstruct some of the
original interview the other aspect is
that you know I designed this format for
this piece you know so we're announcing
the names of the people where so we're
seeing there a little bit of their bio
we're seeing their image kind of like
you might see in a more traditional
documentary but it also you know other
people might want to use this for
their own projects documentary or
otherwise and so because this is based
on this open format for delivering these
stories you can load other stories into
it and so I put it two very very
different uses one of which I will show
here okay so when James Comey book came
out he was doing a lot of interviews and
did one interview I can't remember which
outlet it was it's kind of describing
this conflict with him and Dick Cheney
about surveillance
so that okay this would be an
opportunity to take something that is
described as an interplay between two
figures and actually you know billed it
as something that you could deploy
within the same format so just an
example of how a very different kind of
story could still work in the same
format and basically this is totally
open so you could go and load whatever
story you want into this stage
essentially and put your story in there
so again trying to be a good host trying
to think about other people's content
that might want to work in this place in
this stage and trying to accommodate
that so this is a flyer that I put
together for the Game Developers
Conference this year because I was
trying to go and promote this idea that
you know game developers are creating
these amazing world's amazing
environments with characters in them
they're really making theaters you know
but they're theaters that can usually
only perform one story but if we were to
change the way we thought about these
environments so that we could
accommodate other stories perhaps you
know not not not based in the same
mechanic as the game itself but in a
very simplified step-by-step way of
saying and doing different things that
we can actually open up some really
interesting possibilities here so if
you're thinking about your game as a
theater what would it take for you to
just open up a little bit so that you
could let other people's stories in and
maybe even let your story out into the
rest of the world and not tie it so
tightly to
a particular interface in a particular
mechanic will you allow other shows to
be performed in your theater and will
you allow your work to go other places
some of the things I think this might
enable is some new economic models one
for writers it's really difficult to be
a writer in a digital space if you don't
have a lot of technical skills and you
don't have a team but I think the
ability to kind of distribute stories
independently of the interface could
open some interesting possibilities
where you could see someone actually
monetizing a story that they'd written
that actually isn't tied to a specific
interface but works in many different
interfaces that support that same
standard I think also at my optin offer
new opportunities for developers to
create environments that are really just
meant to host stories they might not
even contain an original story of their
own but they're designed to be evocative
places where stories can play out and be
staged and might have secrets in them
that are you know activated through
certain kinds of actions and things like
that that could be a model in and of
itself which again would also reduce the
amount of labour and development time it
takes to get a project out to the world
so what if this exists now I mean I've
been showing you some demos but just to
kind of be clear about it so there's a
there's a github library and again there
might be some confusion step-wise is the
name of the open source library step
works as the website and the kind of
services that kind of sit around it
so step wise it is open source there is
a JavaScript version version and a Unity
version the Unity version is kind of
interesting because when there's two
sample scenes in it one of which is just
a dist basic demo another which will
actually pull stories from the stepworks
website and show them in a menu and you
can pick one and start to play it and
I'm so kind of hopefully giving folks a
head start on how to play with him and
then you know what if this is an
interest to you what what can you do to
participate well stepworks has been used
successfully in classrooms and workshops
there's a wonderful piece that Zac
Whalen did what he didn't do he taught
the class that was a workshop using it
and one of his students woman named
Elizabeth Brantley did a piece called
two hours with you that is basically
about anxiety
and what she did was she composed nine
different voices basically in this one
character's head that are all having a
debate about when they're gonna wake up
for class and whether they have an
assignment due and whether they actually
completed the assignment or not and then
kind of drifting into some other kind of
issues and questions as well
it's a great piece and again it's
delivered in this format the same kind
of vocal grid format that we saw you
know for the hamilton and the other
examples but you could just as easily
load it into any one of the other stages
and render it in a completely different
way you could even potentially see
bringing it into a unity environment and
having each of these voices kind of
auto-generate as a character in a space
and have you know dynamic camera that's
following the characters as they're
speaking and going through the going
through what they're discussing and so
definitely recommend going to this piece
is on the step work site many of you can
probably relate and check that out okay
so again being a good guest if you're
working with narrative content consider
making that narrative content in a
format that can go out to the world and
can be reused in restaged in different
ways let users potentially export their
past through the content and so that
they can take their own experience and
do something with it
relive it restage it do something
interesting with it be a good host think
about if you're running a platform if
you're creating an environment where
stories are told support speech from
multiple characters play back the
musical notes environmental features
things like time and date and weather
and location these are all things you
can do in the stepwise format now which
can have a really interesting effect and
an environment that supports it so a
little bit about the future
documentation I really need to write
some better documentation there's
there's some there but it's pretty
technical and needs to be much more
friendly so that's my first priority as
I'm moving forward this kind of work
distribution working on getting more
stories more folks that support this
format eventually an authoring tool not
GarageBand but maybe something in
between a spreadsheet and GarageBand
so it's a little more friendly and who
knows you know I'm I'm very interested
in mobilizing stories and platforms
around issues of social justice around
issues of marginalized communities so if
there's something you see that intrigues
you about this please get in touch I
would love to help or if you're
interested in doing a class or something
like that or a workshop please get in
touch I'd be happy happy to help so I'd
like to end on this note almost
literally a note my first programming
language was a musical language called
Forte my dad brought this software home
not long after we got our first Apple 2
which is our first personal computer and
basically it allows you to type notes in
as code and the computer would play them
back it was monophonic it could only
play one note at a time so it was very
limited but my dad who played the
recorder he had some box sheet music and
entered some of those pieces and I was
pretty amazed by what was possible even
though it's a pretty laborious process
and doesn't look very fun again this is
an early predecessor to a format which
got standardized later called MIDI that
enables computers to talk to each other
in a musical way and enabled a whole
bunch of developments lots of different
types of musical software eventually
leading to things like GarageBand or
logic you know the MIDI standard looking
at just at the Wikipedia article prior
to the development of MIDI electronic
musical instruments from different
manufacturers could generally not
communicate with each other the standard
allowed different instruments to
communicate with each other and with
computers and this spurred a rapid
expansion of the sales and production of
electronic instruments in music software
the creative possibilities brought about
by MIDI technology are credited with
helping revive the music industry in the
1980s and a little footnote at the end
educational technology enable by MIDI
has transformed music education so all
is to say I think we need a MIDI for
digital storytelling maybe what I've
shown here tonight is part of that maybe
not but what I'm interested in is seeing
the stories and seeing your stories
become able to move more freely to be
engaged in the world in many different
ways to have that kind of unstuck
quality that allows them to make a great
impact in the world I hope some of what
I've shown today can play a role in that
but at the very least I wish you all the
best in your own creativity and stories
and in making works that impact the
world thank you switch there's a slide
that's supposed to be up
[Music]
I'm here
Oh
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't actually know anybody who's
working on that but I think it's a
fabulous idea and I think it's the kind
of thing that that exactly would be
enabled by a system like this where you
could start to do analysis across you
know multiple stories in a similar
format and start to see you know where
those connection points are you know in
scalar we try and do a microcosm of that
in that as you import media files you
can reuse them but that's just within
one work and we've gotten many requests
from people like I want to connect
multiple works together and see what
these you know relationships might be
and so I think it's definitely something
valuable to to explore
the game
and everybody hear me without the mic
okay yeah great point about machinima
you know and I think these kind of
almost like folk art ways of bringing
narratives into different spaces and
using them and staging them and it is
really important and totally a part of
this whole discussion so yeah I mean if
all that came out of this was people
thought a little bit more about being
good guests and good hosts that would be
great you know I think many of those
practices are still fairly inaccessible
to novices and so while there's a group
of people who have the skills and are
able to do that kind of work that it's
still fairly demanding and not really
intuitive and easy to do so I think
making that easier and more accessible
could have benefits I want to thank both
of the respondents I really appreciate
your words and your comments and
especially the comments about about
whether stories should move that there's
cases where they should and there's
cases when they shouldn't one of the
things we're working on for scaler right
now is an experimental integration with
the Mucca 2 project which is all about
indigenous peoples and First Nations
peoples who are explicitly don't want
their stories to go into all different
kinds of context and it's it's a moral
imperative that they don't that they're
not accessible to everyone and so
building some of those kind of controls
and and warnings and information into
platforms so that it becomes clear when
a story should is intended to circulate
and when it's not intended to circulate
I think that's that's going to be key
[Music]
[Music]
well definitely Google sheets has been
kind of a blessing and a curse in that
way so everybody's familiar with
spreadsheets so on one way that's pretty
accessible and it's pretty easy to
understand
okay columns are characters and rows or
stats stepworks can do more than that it
can do randomization it can do looping
it can do kind of nested groups and
things like that once you started
together that territory it quickly
breaks down as being easy to use because
you start getting the kind of arcane
commands so that's where I really do see
it as a transitional tool that it's
something that's going to evolve into a
more dedicated piece but until then I'm
trying to make it as easy I can and
learning more about actually how Google
sheets works to see if I can make it
even easier while we're in this kind of
you know limbo period you know one of
the things with scaler and the other
tools that I've worked on is that we've
always tried to build tools that are
motivated by what authors and creators
want to be able to do rather than trying
and do I build it and they will come you
know we're like I think this is what you
want and I made it and I put all this
time into making it now why don't you
want it you know that doesn't often work
out but by kind of being intimately
involved with the process by which these
things are created you know you start to
see the trends and the interests of the
folks who are building these building
these pieces and hopefully it can kind
of craft the tools around that that's
[Music]
yeah yeah it's it's not something that
has been done so much yet but I think
it's very much a part of what it could
enable so one example I can point to is
the transition from vectors and those
projects which mostly were built in
flash and we're very kind of closed to
scalar which is just an open source
system that's built on open standards
many people who'd seen the work with
with vectors which is very intricate and
laborious and design very bespoke then
saw scalar and they're like this is so
boring it's so bland like what happened
to you guys you know what have we do I
think was a quote so well we've tried to
make a scalar prettier over time and I
think we've done that there still is
it's a very conventional interface
component compared to these very you
know bespoke interfaces but something
like the nodded line is actually built
on top of scaler so we wanted to show
that you can scaffold you know kind of
the more custom work on top of the
standards-based stuff if you just take
the time to kind of put the standards in
place and I think that speaks a little
bit to what you're talking about where
you could create a completely different
sensory modality for a particular piece
one that requires a lot of very
specialized gear or one that requires
very little specialized gear or that
translate something from text into audio
or things like that so I think there's I
think there's potentially you know a lot
of applications in terms of
accessibility for stories that could be
more automatic than they are right now
I mean I think one thing that could be
interesting there and it's something
we've tried to explore with scaler as
well is you know every scaler project
has an API in it so all the content you
put in you can get back out in an
automated way and in a standards-based
way so there's nothing stopping anyone
from saying give me all the
illustrations from this paper and turn
them into a gallery or in or if the
author were to say okay I want to create
a shorter version of this that's geared
for a general purpose audience as
opposed to the academic audience and
those could all live inside the same
work and you know again it's the things
that I think are enabled by digital
storytelling that we don't see as often
but are definitely there and could be
enhanced by again this ethos of
generosity of I want to make a piece
that different audiences might be able
to encounter and experience in different
ways and really putting the thought into
that in advance so that you come out
with something on the other end that
could actually have the chance of doing
that
right yeah I mean like any anyone
pushing a new technology I'm
enthusiastic about the games and I don't
really want to think about the losses
but I think you know some of the things
that I'm seeing in enabling in my work
are very tight compositions of word and
image and interaction that where every
note every word every syllable I mean so
it's a very you know akin to poetry
versus prose you know are very loaded
and laden and you can compose it in that
way the longer form piece you know the
documentary piece was interesting in
that it it requires a different level of
attention and a different level of
engagement I think in general it is
probably gonna you know privileged
shorter chunks again on the scale of the
musical phrase or the musical note over
longer pieces but it doesn't have to
that's really not kind of built into the
technology I could see that becoming a
pattern of use one of the one of the
pieces that I'm looking at releasing in
the format is actually I have a
collection of 64 Associated Press
stories that came out just before the
2nd Rodney King verdict in the 90s and I
find them fascinating because you know
there's this almost real-time
progression of trying to chart you know
people's fears about what might happen
if this verdict came down versus that
verdict trying to balance all these you
know things going on in the city you
know exhibiting certain biases and kind
of hiding other things and you see it
kind of play out in this journalistic
language that evolves their paragraphs
that start a short paragraphs and then
get expanded as new information is added
and then contract again and you know so
that's an example of a longer set of
texts
that I'd like to release in this format
to see what people might make of it so I
think in a lot of ways it's too early to
know what might be lost in in most cases
I feel like with new technologies we
don't really figure out what we're gonna
be what we're gonna lose until we lose
it which is unfortunate but I think kind
of the way it goes
see I find these talks kind of tend to
go one way or another and I find it's
hard to find a balance between content
and form but yeah I mean a lot of the
interest in in social justice in
politics I get actually from my mom who
was herself an artist a portrait painter
never was interested in really finding
an audience outside of her own practice
but found that practice to be
tremendously healing and impactful for
her as she was trying to kind of create
a community for herself so she painted
mostly african-american faces of singers
and entertainers but where the faces are
cropped very tightly so the face becomes
a kind of landscape and so as I was
growing up I got to see that process
firsthand that she was doing the
research learning more gathering
material honing her technique and so
that just for me is kind of baked in as
you know concerns and things that I'm
interested in one of the greatest gifts
of the vectors process was getting the
chance to collaborate with scholars who
are doing such incredible research in
these areas far beyond any of my
knowledge and getting to kind of absorb
some of their thinking as they went
along and trying to find a form that
would do justice to the research and
kind of represented that way and public
secrets in blue velvet but we're both
very impactful for me in those ways and
kind of exposing me to two new things I
hadn't thought as deeply about nearly as
deeply about as the folks I was
collaborating with so I find that it's a
it's a combination of the concerns I get
from my own back
as well as the people that I work with
and collaborations that kind of keep
animating that and bringing this topics
you know into the work and you know for
me there's are things I'm thinking about
all the time so it's natural for me to
kind of bring them into the projects and
I seek out collaborations where that's
gonna be a big part of the collaboration
because it's something I'm interested in
personally
[Applause]